it looked like the longest war on this
side of the planet had finally ended for
52 years the Colombian government has
been fighting a civil war against the
FARC the Revolutionary Armed Forces of
Colombia Marxist leftist guerrilla
organization that has been bloody and
horrible has cost over 220,000 lives and
displaced over five million people this
has been going on since 1964 and peace
negotiations have been in progress for
four years in Havana Cuba finally in
June there was a break signed a
ceasefire agreement today from walnuts
I'm joined now by in September President
Santos of Colombia and Timoshenko the
leader of the FARC both signed the deal
it was a historic peace agreements
leaders and heads of state from all over
the world came together it was a massive
celebration all that was left was to put
it to a vote to the people it was a
formality part of the deal the polls
showed it winning the deal was going to
pass and it didn't everyone was wrong
all the polls were wrong it was a really
close vote 50.2% voted against it
why would Colombians vote against such a
momentous peace agreement there are a
few reasons and to understand let's go
back to 1964 in the mid 60s there were a
lot of leftist Marxist communist type
rebellions and particularly in South
America and Latin America you might
recognize this guy or this one they took
over nearby Cuba the FARC claimed to
represent the interests of a lot of the
rural people in Colombia
there was intense inequality here's an
example point two percent of farms owned
30% of farmland this inequality had
fueled a previous civil war from 1946 to
58 - with two million peasant farmers
forced off their land Manuel sure-shot
Merril andhe took up their cause forming
FARC in the 60s after a government
assault on communist groups he wanted
the government to redistribute land back
to the poor and rid the country of
multinational companies but they ended
up funding their fight in horrifying
ways the FARC specifically got
especially powerful and
and wealthy from capitalizing on the
drug trade that they're taking a lot of
the wealth from the drug trade and using
that to kind of funnel back into their
rebellion they used kidnappings and
ransoms this way to some of the
kidnapped were forced to fight they
recruited child soldiers they there was
a lot of sexual violence a lot of rape
all of this should give you a sense why
many Colombians opposed the specifics of
the peace deal the FARC agreed to end
their drug trafficking to give away
their weapons total addictive idol
conflict oh they do community service
removing their landmines they have to
turn over all of their weapons to
special UN inspectors who would be on
the grounds but in return they'd face no
jail time the FARC would also get five
guaranteed seats in each of Colombia's
two houses of Congress in financial aid
for fighters who'd immobilize de groups
on the right and the government also
engaged in plenty of crimes so it wasn't
just the FARC this sounded like justice
and forgiveness to some but to others it
sounded like surrender the previous
President of Colombia or Ebay led the
campaign to vote against the deal he
said repeatedly he wasn't against peace
he wasn't against a peace agreement in
principle in fact he had led a crackdown
on the FARC that had brought them to the
negotiating table in the first place
with heavy support from the US
government top leadership was killed a
lot of people demobilized and disarms
they went from something like 20,000
fighters at their peak to down to us
between six and seven thousand fighters
it was effective I'm kind of brought
them to the negotiating table
Uribe clearly wasn't satisfied by the
negotiations outcome this suite is
representative with these agreements
there is no justice nor truth but the
thing is if you look at a map of how
people voted some of the areas that were
hardest hit by the conflict they voted
yes most strongly in boy aha the site of
one of the FARC worst massacres a
bombing of a church and 119 dead 96%
voted for the peace agreement
and now everything is in complete
disarray it's unclear what's gonna even
happen but at this point they cannot
implement the peace agreement as agreed
at least one thing is sure the FARC and
Colombia have not gone back to war at
least not yet
a ceasefire is still in effect reaffirm
ahmo's ante Colombia y el mundo que sus
frente de y ellos en todo el pais
permanence Aaron en ceci a Lego billet
Errol definitive Oh como una necesaria
medida de Alivio las víctimas del
conflict o en respeto al recorded o con
el gobierno nazuna and Santos the
current president and Erie Bay the
former who opposed the deal met for the
first time in six years and vowed to
work toward peace given anyone under 60
in Colombia has basically only known a
country at war let's hope they succeed
[Music]
you